what's going on guys this is rob and i
have been on an alex
ross kick recently so we're going to
cover superman peace on earth now
for a lot of you guys who are new to
comic books in general
alex ross is the comic book artist right
so much so that this guy's work costs
thousands of dollars right like if you
go and you look up alex ross art you'll
see our pieces that range anywhere from
800 bucks to 25 grand
i mean it's it's kind of nuts and
there's a reason for that the style of
alex ross is called photo realism but
more so than that the way he depicts
characters he usually depicts them in a
way that's reminiscent of like the
golden age of comics and whenever i see
alex ross art it kind of reminds me of a
time when it makes me nostalgic for an
era that i didn't grow up in
where there was no uh confusion between
superheroes and super villains right
that there was no moral ambiguity
superheroes did good things
super villains did bad things and that
was it there was no middle ground so
essentially comics as they existed
pre-crisis and so
superman peace on earth is as far as i'm
concerned the single greatest superman
story that's ever been written in the
history of comic books it is absolutely
incredible so hopefully you guys dig
this as much as i do but the thing kind
of opens up with clark kent sort of
reminiscing
on his time talking to his father and as
a farmer his
father's job of course was to grow crops
but there was almost kind of a
philosophy that went into it and so far
as was what his father taught him and
this is kind of given to us by pauldini
and alex ross
as this idea that there's simply more to
this
life of superman or this philosophy of
superman than just like a guy with
powers who does some stuff
that a lot of the moral compass he was
given when he was younger was instilled
in this moment when his father basically
told him that when it comes to the seeds
that we're planting here when it comes
to these crops that we're trying to grow
not all of them are going to make it but
each one deserves a chance to grow
and that kind of a philosophy really
went forward with superman
and looking at this idea that not
everybody in the world is going to do
inherently good things
not everybody in the world is going to
make the world a better place but they
deserve the opportunity to demonstrate
that they can't
and this story really focuses on that
more so than anything else and so
kind of picking up in the modern era one
of the things that's given to us is that
kind of a hallmark and really a
tradition
for superman is basically bringing the
christmas tree to metropolis now this is
really just kind of the metropolis
version
of like lighting the christmas tree at
rockefeller center right you guys know
that it's this great big huge
you know to do in new york and really
even in the united states as a whole
right for those of you guys who are
outside the states the lighting of the
christmas tree at rockefeller center is
something that's watched by people
around the entirety of the u.s
right i mean i wouldn't say that they
you know look at it with a kind of
reverence but it's just one of those
things that we do
and so superman bringing this here is
one of those instances where metropolis
sees it as a kind of tradition here
comes superman bringing the tree
and it's kind of cool because he talks
about how when he does this of course
news reporters are trying to get quotes
out of him and everybody's trying to get
pictures and all that kind of stuff but
in the middle of this as he leaves he
hears this kind of cry for help right
that's very very whispery almost faint
sound on the air and he swoops down now
the importance of this and really the
reason why this is so cool is because
the entirety of the world's greatest
superheroes line of comics
is designed to give us these mainstay
superheroes right wonder woman shazam
batman superman designed to give us this
kind of depiction in terms of how they
would really function
in a in a very real and tangible level
right to strip away the mythos and to
give us the actual characters themselves
and a core aspect of superman is
regardless of who you are
i can hear you if you're struggling and
so this girl kind of letting off this
little bit of a
scream superman swoops her up and then
realizes how light she is and then comes
to the realization she didn't pass out
out of shock right oh my god superman
just scooped me up she passes out
because she's so hungry right because
she's basically starving and so he ends
up taking her to a local rescue mission
dropping her off he knows the person
there rebecca mason will basically
ensure this girl is fed that she's taken
care of and then superman starts to kind
of look around
and this is an important thing here
because when you're somebody likes
superman despite the fact that you are
kind of the hero of the world it's very
easy for a lot of the world's struggles
to kind of escape your notice not
because of the fact that superman is a
terrible superhero who's just like i
only really care about fighting you know
lex luthor but because of the fact that
there's a lot of struggle that goes on
in the world and while there is a desire
to fix those things there's more
immediate threats that happen
in the here and now but in this moment
there's a bit of a respite there is no
lex luthor trying to destroy metropolis
or conquer the world there's no metallo
going through and destroying everything
doomsday is not running amuck there's
not really any of that stuff it's
basically a respite it's a chance for
superman to just kind of
look around in this little bit of a
break and say what can i actually do to
fix this world and so as clark kent he
actually starts
traveling around to these different
places right just kind of visiting these
different rescue missions and things
like that and
asking about people's stories right he
asked about this little girl that he
dropped off at the mission they say her
name's jody she's a runaway from a poor
southern town that she thought there
would be better opportunities in
metropolis but with no job and no
friends she was reduced to begging and
so she was malnourished and she might
have died had it not been for superman
and that's when he kind of looks around
and realizes
this girl is not an anomaly right she's
it's not a kind of one-off thing that
this happens
all the time and not only does it just
happen in metropolis it happens across
the world in various countries
all over the place and so instead of
going to the traditional holiday party
at the daily planet
instead he goes to basically the the
research office right he goes like these
these kind of historical texts about
various things that are happening around
the world that all the reporters
basically cite whenever they're writing
stories or where they store
information after they're done with
their stories and he starts looking for
information on world hunger right that
he wants to learn about his causes its
effects
its possible solutions and so he starts
zipping through all these different
pages and realizes how rough it is in
the world and so kind of amusing back
thinking back on the lessons that he
learned from his father that one of the
most important things that that his dad
told him is he said the problem
is people as far back as we go we've
always had problems with
sharing it seems someone's too busy
holding on to what they've got to care
about how their neighbors are doing and
that's
true right when there's a chicken in
every pot everything's grand but when
there's one chicken and 10 pots nobody
cares about the other people and so it's
one of these things where his father
doesn't really approach this
inherent selfish nature of humanity from
a cynical standpoint and saying
and that son is why humanity sucks
that's not what he says
instead it's just like that's the gift
of you is that
these are the kind of things that humans
do but because we don't know any better
i mean we
could do better but what we need is
somebody to show us what we could be
doing better right that's the role of
superman
the role of superman is to be a kind of
guiding light for humanity to help
humanity evolve and change
and to simply become better to basically
say like this like what we're doing here
is not good enough even if we think it
is it's not and he thinks back on his
life as a superhero the way that he
saved people from burning buildings or
he saved people from
flooding towns and then kind of brought
them to us to a place of safety you know
saving saving people from
trains that are crashing or from planes
that are going to come crashing down
because an engine busted he thinks of
all these different things and he says
but at the end of the day
that's a momentary thing right like i am
saving those people
in the moment from you know whatever
this thing happens to be but there's no
cascading effects here right it's not as
though because this train had some kind
of a bridge malfunction and the train
was going to go careening to its death
that everybody's going to analyze every
single train track across the united
states and fix it i
need to think bigger i need to think on
a more broad scale i need to be
or create an example that other people
can follow and so what he does
is he actually goes and speaks directly
to congress and this draws a huge amount
of attention
because it's something that superman
never does right and this this is the
way this story is written in his history
he never goes to congress
and addresses the government more so
than that when he does this what he
basically says here is
looking at hunger as it exists right
this little girl jody kind of being
an example here this is a worldwide
issue right hunger is a worldwide thing
that it's not something that exists
in some poor part of new york or chicago
or california
it's not just a u.s problem this is a
worldwide problem
and that this kind of issue of
boundaries and so on and so forth of
countries differentiating themselves
from other countries
exacerbates this problem and while he's
not necessarily preaching this notion of
like we should eliminate all borders and
just unify into one singular government
what he does propose
is a solution in saying that the us
basically has more than it needs right
we have all this grain and all these
resources a lot of which just sits
inside these giant silos or or
stockpiles some of which
actually goes bad before we can give it
away to anybody else and so he says
instead of just letting all this stuff
go to waste we don't have the means to
transport it so i'll do it i will
transport all this stuff
across the world to all these different
countries everywhere and initially he's
met by
a wide range of reactions everything
from we knew superman was going to be
able to do great things too there's no
way he can pull that off right like
literally there are people who are
supportive and people who are skeptical
even people who downright say
the u.s has no business doing any of
this stuff for the rest of the world
right if they could get it together they
would have gotten it together and so
there's no point in helping those people
because they won't even help themselves
but at the end of the day he basically
starts harvesting all this grain and
starts bringing all these resources
together which is a monumental task
and then sets about the world uh
basically starting with the american
southwest
about how this entire area is rough and
bitter and harsh especially in the
winter time but even during any time of
the year right i mean a lot of you guys
know that you look like anything outside
of phoenix and even in phoenix itself
it's just the desert man like it's just
a rough place to live and so grabbing a
huge amount of resources he drops them
off in front of this old man
and says these are for your people the
only thing i ask is that you make sure
that they get the resources that they
need and this guy's like
yes and then superman moves on to the
next location where he says he flies
south to countries
where there's almost no middle ground
between wealth and poverty the great
city below
is a painful example of that distance he
says from up here
it looks like a jewel bright and
beautiful but down below there's favelas
right talking about brazil
the crowded slums where children bathe
in gutter water families live in boxes
and rats run
openly in the streets there's a huge
amount of
poverty in this place and so dropping
these resources off to the people in the
favelas he in turn
celebrates the idea and even really
spends time with some of these kids when
they rush to him they celebrate they're
like yeah superman's here to help us
superman's here to save us right
excited about this whole thing and then
moves on to basically europe now the way
this is kind of given to us
it's eastern europe which has largely
since just been a
rough place to be ever since the fall of
the berlin wall and really at the end of
world war ii that eastern europe never
really seemed to recover at least not in
the same pace
as other countries out there right
western europe things like that and so
the people here in this land have seen
untold horrors right they've seen
horrible things that they have
generations of their family line that
have experienced nothing but just
trouble
and and struggle and sacrifice and loss
death
all kinds of different things and so
superman's showing up here and handing
these people these resources that no one
really says anything to him
instead as he stands there with his arms
open it's a silent experience right and
that silence is just breathtaking that
no one really says anything they just
kind of move forward they take some of
what he has and then they go back
silently right almost as if they're
fearful of him and so only one little
kid speaks up and they ask him are you
going to come back tomorrow and he
simply says that he looks away
and he kind of talks about that for a
second right he says that he flies as
fast as he can from one location to the
next
and that he knows that he can't do this
every single day right that he shouldn't
even try because he knows that all it'll
do is set the world up for failure but
the idea here
isn't to solve the world's problems by
just giving people what they need that
what he's looking to do
is get the rest of the world to start
thinking about a permanent solution he's
leading by example
and so from there things start to get a
little more bleak and the reason why is
of course he shows up
in a section of africa and while the
experience here is not necessarily a
bleak one there is a wildfire raging off
in the distance it'll actually reach
this local village within minutes and so
of course you have animals who are
trying to escape it
and basically lead to a massive stampede
so he creates a bit of a trench that
kind of drives some of the animals away
but the bigger ones like you know
elephants and rhinoceroses uh lions as
he describes it they need
a little more persuasion but he ends up
going to a local lake creating a kind of
uh water spout and then using that to
put the fire out in this this local town
and then he moves to another location
basically to a place in asia now a lot
of this seems to be vietnam the way it's
given to us just the kind of tropical
look that this place has
it looks like vietnam and when he
arrives here the vietnamese leader is
there and says thank you superman for
providing us with these resources
there's no need for you to stay here my
friend
i will make sure that our people are
tended to i will make sure
that the food is dispersed among our
people equally now superman knows
right off the bat this guy's full of
huha juice right he knows he's lying the
smile he has on his face is is about the
most fake smile
anybody could have and he knows this
really just because of the fact that
he's a reporter that he's reported on
this part of the world and he knows that
what's actually going to happen here
is that this guy is going to take up all
these resources and his people are
virtually going to get none of it and
then if they do get any of it they'll
get
tiny little tidbits just enough to keep
them dependent instead what'll happen
with these resources is he will feed his
soldiers he'll feed himself and then
he'll sell off the rest right make money
for his country
and so superman is faced with a bit of a
quagmire here and that's one of the
things that he addresses it'd be
easy for him to just take out this
dictator right to just kill this guy
wipe out his troops and leave the people
to run their land but at the end of the
day superman's not here to topple
dictators superman's here to to kind of
establish a lesson to basically teach
the world that they can become better
than what they are right now and so
while superman responds and says i can
appreciate the fact that you're the
leader of this country and i'm not
looking to step on your toes but i would
feel a lot more comfortable
if i just simply dropped this food off
here and left it to the people
and then in turn they take what they
need and then you basically take the
rest if you even need it at all and so
in turn as superman begins to disperse
this food this guy nods to his soldiers
and 20 assault rifles fire now superman
blocks every single one of these bullets
and in turn the food is dispersed among
these people they run and grab it but
here's a kicker to this and it's the one
thing that superman knows that yes he's
here to protect the people right now but
this dictator and superman both know
eventually he's going to have to leave
he can't stand as a sentinel
protecting this food and ensuring this
guy never takes out his people
because there are other threats that
superman needs to deal with and so it's
one of these things where he's like as
soon as you're gone i'm taking it all
right like i will i'll do whatever i
need to do even if it means taking it
from the mouths of these people as
they're eating it but you can't stay
here forever
so sure you fed them for a day but i'm
gonna get my due and so again kind of
traveling from one location to the next
he actually encounters areas where
nobody will come out and meet him that
he drops these resources off and these
people are so
terrified they live in such incredible
fear that they don't come out to meet
him at all
instead as he drops the food off he
basically ends up leaving to find that
like these rats have kind of fed on a
little bit and then eventually they'll
come out and they'll start partaking in
it but at the end of the day they don't
trust outsiders
there's other locations that he travels
to where even the citizens themselves
reject him right where they're like no
we don't want you here like we don't
want any of your your help or anything
like that like you're not one of us you
need to stay away there's places that he
goes to
where because the people are so
incredibly starved because they're
they're living in such decrepit
conditions such bleak conditions that
they've almost lost their humanity
any sense of order and structure is gone
and so as he gets there they immediately
set upon him and he actually has to
burrow underground
and escape and they don't even know he's
gone right they don't even know that
he's that he's basically left superman
encounters these situations over and
over and over again but eventually he
comes across a scenario
as he's flying this kind of tanker of
resources across the world where there
are governments out there there are
groups out there that look at it
look at superman himself and what it is
he's doing here and providing what is
potentially
liberation among their people that these
governments have kept their people in
such a condition to where they're so
dependent that they can't really even
consider the possibility
of somebody else taking care of them
outside of whoever this government
happens to be
and in order to ensure that power is
maintained in order to ensure their
people
do not consider the possibility that
somebody else out there could actually
take care of them
they fire off a missile and destroy the
entirety of the tanker
and that's the most crushing experience
to superman because in turn this missile
has also contained a poison of sorts and
so while a lot of the screen is
completely and totally destroyed
what little grain is left is poisoned
there's nothing he can do now there's no
one else that he can feed
the entire mission is completely
scrubbed and that's the biggest problem
that's the biggest crushing thing
that superman has to contend with is
that in the face
of trying to make the world a better
place he's not met by some
invisible being out there that's kind of
composed of pure evil
and trying to destroy him it's not like
the specter has been taken over by some
evil entity and is trying to kill
superman
right it's not some alien that comes
from space at the end of the day
mankind's biggest enemy is itself that
sometimes
you just can't save people from
themselves and then he in turn looks at
it and says maybe the biggest mistake
that i made here was actually trying to
feed the world right like maybe that's
the the biggest issue that i have here
what i should be doing
is actually doing the one thing that
people would despise the most
forcing them to acknowledge this
situation exists
forcing people who would otherwise look
away right in the modern era we would
call that social media right just kind
of you know
typing things out but never actually
doing things or just pretending that
this kind of situation doesn't exist
turning your head away and just kind of
being like there's there's nothing going
on over there right and if there is well
there's nothing i can do about it so i'm
not i'm just not going to worry about it
that instead what he does is he forces
people to acknowledge the fact that this
kind of thing exists and he does it by
using
the power of the press by writing
articles by basically going through and
saying these like the kind of things
that i've seen here the things that i've
seen around the world there's no
conceivable reason why
these people should be should be
suffering there's no conceivable reason
why
these governments should be continuing
to operate if anything while we can't
necessarily go in
and quash every single governmental
threat that exists out there
every desperator dictator or whoever
what we can do is implement policies we
can we can
implement sanctions on them we can kind
of starve out their governments and so
they have to change and while there will
be a bit of collateral damage insofar as
their people
at the end of the day the ends do
justify the means because we're
basically forcing the hand of those
governments right like one of those big
things where he's kind of like we're a
huge resource in the world so we should
use that to our advantage and kind of
inspiring people and saying there's so
much more that we can do in this world
there's a lot that we can achieve here
and so it's one of these things where he
really kind of ends this little bit of a
discussion here and saying that the
welfare of earth and all its people will
always be my primary concern but if
there is a solution to the problem of
hunger it must be one that comes from
the compassionate heart of man
and extends outward towards his fellow
man and he says there's an old saying
give a man a fish
and he eats for a day teach him to fish
and he eats for a lifetime he says that
simple message asks humankind
to nurture with knowledge to reach out
to those in need
and inspire others to do the same that's
life's greatest necessity and its most
precious gift and so he writes here i
ask everyone to share what they have
with those who need it their knowledge
their time their generosity
especially with the young for on them
rest our future
and all hope of a true peace on earth so
again the idea the story superman peace
on earth is one of the single greatest
superman stories
ever written we've also got batman war
on crime i'm pretty sure we already did
that and i think we did shazam
uh the power of hope i'm pretty sure we
did shazam the power of hope is like the
most amazing story
ever but it's just like emotionally
devastating at the same time it's like
the saddest story ever like i teared up
man
i almost started crying when i read that
story i was like oh my god
it's so good but i'll link i'll link the
playlist for both of those down in the
description
if you guys are interested in seeing
more of these let me know because i
believe there's the one with wonder
woman and i don't think we did that
and then there's world's greatest
superheroes the justice league and i
think that's the last one i don't think
they did anymore after that i don't
think there were any more
that came after that but let me know you
guys think down in the comments thank
you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace